Traduttore: Stefania Recchia
Revisore: Martina Pia Ruino
Circa tre anni fa
ho avuto la fortuna
di cominciare ad incontrare
delle persone veramente speciali,
entrare in delle storie fuori dal comune:
storie di persone con patologie gravi,
spesso incurabili,
storie dei loro angeli custodi,
mogli, mariti, figli, genitori,
anche medici e assistenti
che si prendono cura di loro.
Storie di sofferenza,
ma anche dove si respira
tantissimo amore.
Pazienti con patologie come la SLA,
una patologia neurodegenerativa,
ma anche tetraplegie
di natura ischemica
o con conseguenze da traumi.
Avrete sicuramente visto in qualche caso,
avrete l'immagine di qualche paziente
in situazioni di cosidetto
"locked-in",
ovvero completamente immobile,
incapace di parlare,
ma che tramite l'ausilio
di tecnologie come ad esempio
il puntatore oculare
interagisce tramite il computer
con le persone
e con l'ambiente.
Ebbene ci sono delle persone
che non possono utilizzare
queste tecnologie,
ed è su queste che ci siamo concentrati
e alcuni di questi, da alcuni mesi,
hanno potuto riprendere a comunicare,
dopo mesi o anni.
È stato possibile grazie a una tecnologia,
che si chiama Brain Computer Interface,
una tecnologia che consente
d'intercettare l'attività elettrica
sulla corteccia cerebrale,
tramite dei sensori elettroencefalografici
e, in corrispondenza
di determinati pensieri,
poter utilizzare questi stimoli
per controllare un computer.
Una tecnologia a cui mi sono
avvicinato circa sei anni fa,
e che all'inizio mi è sembrata
come una sorta di bestia indomabile,
perché 20 anni di ricerche --
però aveva prodotto dei laboratori --
dei prototipi pressoché limitati
all'interno delle mura di laboratorio.
Però mi sono convinto
che questa risorsa formidabile,
sebbene complessa,
da questa risorsa si potesse
tirar fuori qualcosa di utile,
di usabile,
per lo meno per pazienti
in queste situazioni.
Ed è li che è cominciato questo percorso,
percorso di studio, che ha portato
a un'analisi di fattibilità dei prototipi
e a individuare
un particolare filone,
quello che sfrutta
delle immagini di movimento.
Quando noi pensiamo
di muovere le nostre mani
o le gambe, in avanti, indietro,
a destra e a sinistra,
il pensiero che anticipa
il movimento stesso,
quindi sia che noi siamo
poi in grado o meno
di muovere i nostri arti,
questa attività cerebrale
che si viene a creare
può essere intercettata
e sfruttata come una sorta
di joystick mentale.
Quindi un joystick mentale per controllare
dei dispositivi assistivi:
la carrozzina elettrica,
il controllo della domotica, delle luci,
quindi l'ambiente più in generale,
ma anche la comunicazione,
quindi tramite la sintesi vocale
e così via.
Vi faccio adesso vedere un video
in cui ci siamo focalizzati
proprio sulla comunicazione
in quanto facendo un'analisi
di quello che potevano essere
le priorità da dare allo sviluppo,
quello che è emerso è stato ovviamente --
pensiamo al caso della SLA,
una patologia emblematica,
veramente crudele,
in cui si perde il controllo
dei muscoli progressivamente,
quindi questo va a impattare
inizialmente sugli stili di vita,
e quindi nell'interazione
con i propri cari,
con i propri familiari.
Andando avanti
anche l'autonomia nel nutrirsi,
nel respirare viene meno,
ma addirittura dall'impossibilità
di muovere le palpebre
ne determina anche l'incapacità di vedere,
di osservare, di guardare.
Ora noi, le nostre necessità
per sopravvivere sono
sicuramente alimentarsi,
sicuramente respirare
ma la comunicazione è fondamentale.
Noi abbiamo bisogno
di relazionarci con gli altri.
E quindi è emerso chiaro
che la comunicazione
era il primo passo
su cui bisognava lavorare.
Il video che vi faccio vedere
è focalizzato sulla comunicazione
è una tecnologia diciamo…
Rientra fra le tecnologie
di comunicazione aumentativa alternativa
e con un'interazione
estremamente semplice,
perché da questo si doveva partire,
vedrete che ci sono anche
dei feedback audio
che consentono per l'appunto a persone
che non possono guardare lo schermo,
di poter essere guidate
in questa tipologia di supporto.
Vediamo il video.
Qui c'è un semplice selettore di risposte
"sì/no, non lo so",
da cui generalmente cominciamo,
quindi come primo passo,
il più semplice.
Mentre in questo secondo caso
è una griglia
un po' più articolata,
quindi con una maggiore
libertà di espressione, più livelli,
per aumentare un po'
la possibilità d'interazione.
Ebbene questa, sebbene semplice,
interazione,
ha consentito negli ultimi mesi
a dei pazienti
che non avevano delle alternative
per poter comunicare,
di poter comunicare i propri bisogni,
le proprie necessità,
anche malesseri in alcuni casi.
Potrei raccontarvi degli aneddoti,
quello sicuramente
a cui più sono affezionato,
è quello di un signore
che è da sei anni in locked-in,
non si sapeva, non si aveva certezza
di quale fosse il suo stato cognitivo,
poiché non era in grado
di dare dei feedback.
Dopo due sessioni di training
ha cominciato
a darci delle conferme,
a rispondere in modo preciso
a delle domande e una delle prime cose
che gli abbiamo chiesto è,
aprendogli le palpebre,
se era in grado di vedere.
Ha detto di sì.
Ha visto per la prima volta
il nipote di cinque anni.
Potete immaginare che emozione.
(Applausi)
Ma ce ne sarebbero tanti altri:
un padre che ha potuto
per la prima volta dire un ciao
alla propria figlia di quattro anni,
in quanto in quel periodo
della sua nascita
era entrato in questa situazione
di incapacità di comunicare.
Quindi è solo il primo passo sicuramente,
stiamo lavorando su controlli più avanzati
stiamo lavorando anche sulla robotica
e su scheletri robot-umanoidi,
anche cose un po' più futuristiche,
però era un passo importante da compiere.
Questa è un'immagine
a cui sono affezionato
è Sausalito, in California,
una foto che ho scattato due anni fa.
Sullo sfondo San Francisco,
in primo piano dei sassi,
in equilibrio uno sull'altro,
che un signore
dai tratti orientali
metteva lì sulla spiaggia
e che in quel momento,
questa precarietà
di questi sassi,
a volte ci si appoggiavano
dei gabbiani facendoli cadere,
ma non sempre,
alcune volte inspiegabilmente
rimanevano ancora in piedi.
Mi ha riportato l'immagine
di questi pazienti,
dello stato di queste persone
con cui ero entrato in contatto,
una precarietà quotidiana, legata proprio
all'evolvere della malattia.
Però è nata in me
la convinzione che un'idea
può essere incisiva
al punto di cambiare
un destino che sembra segnato.
Pensate a questi pazienti che arrivano
giorno dopo giorno,
consapevoli di qual è
l'evoluzione della malattia
e quale doveva essere
il loro percorso, il loro destino.
Quindi come si può cambiare
un flusso di un corso d'acqua,
è possibile cambiare delle storie.
L'acqua che ritroviamo
in quest'altra immagine,
immagine dei bottini di Siena,
Siena è la mia città adottiva.
I bottini sono
un'opera ingegnosa e maestosa:
sono 25 chilometri di cunicoli sotterranei
dove l'acqua scorre per gravità,
scorre grazie a una percettibile pendenza,
passa attraverso
delle vasche di decantazione,
dei filtri, fino ad arrivare alle fonti.
Un'opera che nel sedicesimo secolo
ha consentito
a questa città di svilupparsi,
di prosperare
pur in assenza di sorgenti naturali,
di percorsi d'acqua naturali,
cosa che era indispensabile
a quel tempo.
Ebbene, qui ci vedo
come un'idea combinata
con l'ingegno, con la determinazione,
può cambiare la storia.
E voglio finire con un altro video.
Un video divertente,
che testimonia senz'altro
il potenziale di questa tecnologia.
Grazie.
(Applausi)